hello in this video I would talk about
protein folding in the ER ER or that
endoplasmic reticulum is considered to
be the production house of the cell it
is just like a factory inside a factory
there are several machines which are
ensuring the product is properly made
packaged and delivered to its warehouse
similarly ER has several machineries by
which it can fold the proteins properly
packaged it properly and can send it to
qual key which is the warehouse of the
cell now protein production happens on
the poly line goes on complex in the
cytosol and also bound ribosome on the
ER surface now in the poly ribosome
complex when the new newly synthesized
protein proteins are forming there is a
signal recognition particle which
attached to the end of the newly
synthesized protein now on the ear
membrane there is a receptor known as
signal recognition particle which
quickly binds to the signal recognition
which which binds to the signal
recognition particle now assertive
receptors actually transfer those Palio
some complex to the translocation
channels and the translocation channel
allow the nascent polypeptide to come in
now inside the ear lumen there are
several chaperones which are proteins
which can fold the nascent polypeptides
into a complete protein
now chaperones of hsp70 family also
known as VIP is one of the most
important chaperone in the ER other
chaperones include calnexin and
calreticulin now calnexin and
calreticulin help twofold understand
polypeptide chain where as p IP prevents
immature or improper folding of a
nascent polypeptide now calnexin or B IP
these ear chaperones are just like those
specific trends or specific machines in
the factory which ensures the product is
properly
made now calnexin and calreticulin
they're basically calcium binding lectin
so they recognize as a nickname they
would recognize glucose contain a link
to oligosaccharides now the terminal
mono glucose linked any in linked
oligosaccharides of a nascent
polypeptide is recognized by Cal Cal
mixing no so what happens is when the
once the protein is properly folded by
the connection complex
another enzyme known as glucose it is
cleave off the last glucose residue as a
result the fully folded mature protein
is ready to leave the ER but what
happens when the protein is improperly
folded or Mis folded then what happens
there are several enzymes known as
glucose I transference which would
transfer a glucose moiety to the in
linked oligosaccharides and which would
lead to the attachment of the misfolded
protein to the calnexin complex and the
protein would be properly fold it again
and then would be delivered to call him
thus calnexin calreticulin and VIP are
like specific quality control checkers
in this whole big factory of the same
and they ensures that protein is
properly folded and all the misfolded
proteins could be refold it and then
sent back to the goal game for delivery
to the specific locations of the cell
that is how stringent quality control
inside the cell is maintained if you
liked my video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
thank you